hey guys chastity here here at gamespot  we love more than just video games we  also love to geek out over TV shows  movies and comics so much that we have a  dedicated channel on YouTube just for  our entertainment content it's called  gamespot universe from Star Wars  features to the latest movie trailers to  recaps of your favorite shows gamespot  universe is our permanent home for  movies TV and comics as a January third  our team is working hard on making great  features for you and I host and narrate  a lot of the videos there come geek out  with us we want to know what kind of  videos you'd like to see subscribe to  gamespot universal you never miss a  video I'm chassis and I'll see you there  [Music]